Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner's welcome to another of our podcasts. On this podcast,
we are going to address some questions that you have that we've said to my solicitors.
And the question that we want to address today is fatigue and cancer. The question is why
does a cancer patient have fatigue? Quite specifically, why do I have so much fatigue with my cancer?
Let's jump right into that. So a main reason why a person with cancer would have fatigue has to do
with edemia. So there's different types of edemia. There is a type of edemia that will be seen on
a CBC, on a blood test that will show red blood cells in hemoglobin. That's called edemia of chronic
disease. Now when we talk about a person with cancer, we know what the chronic disease is. So
why would a cancer patient have edemia? Well, several reasons. But one other reason is the most
common reason is that cancer cells, okay, so cells that are in a state of rapid replication,
are going to draw a lot of iron. They're indeed iron for replenishment of cellular membranes and
cellular tissue that is being created in the replication of new cells. They're going to need energy.
They're going to need oxygen. So iron is going to be depleted in a rapidly replicating cancer. So
person with cancer and the cancer is growing and increased growth is taking place. One of the first
signs that you're going to see is a relative edemia. So when you do a blood test, you see a low red blood
cell count. You see a low hemoglobin count. And you know you have a cancer diagnosis. That's one of the
first things you're going to consider. Now one of the things that your doctor may recommend is that you
start taking iron supplementation in this case. You will not be able to get a transfusion unless
your hemoglobin is typically below 7, 7.5 depended on the rules of that hospital. But iron supplementation
may be an order. The problem is is that I said a growing cancer tends to gobble up iron. Now that
can be an issue. Am I just feeding my cancer by adding iron supplementation? Well, yes and no.
First of all, let's state that the type of iron that a person should take, whether if cancer or not,
should be a whole food form iron. Typically what's recommended is a ferrous sulfate. I don't recommend
that. That will typically constipate a person. It's very difficult to digest and the absorption rate
is low and the usability rate once it gets into the blood is low. We recommend a food base iron that's
going to be better absorbed. It's not going to cause any of the issues with gut issues that ferrous sulfate
will. Secondly, will iron supplementation be the smart thing to do if it's going to feed my cancer?
Well, it isn't in a situation of catch 22 because we don't want to leave a person in a state of anemia
that's going to be fatigued. That's going to cause all sorts of issues. But the knowledge that
there are certain cancer-killing herbs that tend to follow iron, we can take advantage of that.
So if a person has anemia, typically we recommend a food base iron supplement plus taking the herb
are to missin it. Are to missin it is an herb that can be a cancer killer. And since it tends to
follow iron by coupling it with iron with a person with anemia, if the cancer is gobbling up the iron
and it will gobble up the are to missin it as well. And that can be beneficial to help kill the
growing cancer. So typically we recommend taking are to missin it with the iron supplementation.
And that's going to be your best bet. Now, it's difficult to deal with a rapidly replicated
cancer that's gobbling up iron solely with supplementation. So you want to make sure that you're getting a
CBC a blood test done so that your kebab moment isn't dropping below that range. And we do
recommend you either get packed red blood cells or a transfusion. If it does drop below that right,
it can be very beneficial as far as how you feel it can make you feel like the world of difference.
Another reason, another type of anemia that you can give with cancer is B12 deficiency anemia.
That is not an uncommon problem as well. So if you're going to take B12 supplementation, again,
you can do a blood test to fight this out. But if you're going to take B12 supplementation or if you're
cancer patient, you're currently taking B12 just for health benefits. Make sure you look at the back
of your model. We don't recommend methylated B12, but it'll say methylcovalamine. And the reason is
that methyl groups, though, they're so beneficial for all of us, for cancer patients. What methyl groups do
is they turn off genes. And many people, especially with MTHFR, defects can have a deficiency in methyl
groups and that could be an issue. And then taking methylcovalamine might be in the order. But typically
for cancer patients, we don't recommend supplementing with methyl groups. You're going to get enough dietary
methyl groups by eating your vegetables and your greens. We don't recommend supplementing with
methylfolate or methylcovalamine because it will, it can, paid in our heads hinder, by turning off
to the suppressor genes. And we don't want to turn off to the suppressor genes. So we don't use
methyl groups in our office. That's your choice. We typically recommend if we're going to use B12
hydroxylcamolamine or a denticelcamolamine. They're both very available. They're available in our
store most clinics. And you can buy them online. Hydroxylcamolamine are a denticelcamolamine,
not methylcamolamine, not cyanocamolamine. Another reason why a person can be deficient or can have
energy deficiency with cancer is simply that the growing cancer is gobbling up your ATP, your energy
sources. So there's a lot of ATP, a lot of energy that's required to produce new cells. That's
what's taking place with a growing cancer. So that can be an issue as well. So we do not recommend
supporting with mitochondrial supplements. That's very common out there in the natural marketplace.
That's not what we recommend with cancer because you could be supporting the mitochondria
of the cancer cells themselves. You do want to look at if this is the case, is the person eating
enough? That is a common problem with later stage cancer especially. The person doesn't have an appetite.
They're not eating enough and they're just not eating enough calories. So getting good quality calories,
not just some of the prepared drinks that are out there are not a good choice. You want good quality
calories with good quality fats with cancer. So make sure you contact your office about that as well.
Okay, so hopefully that covers some broader things about the energy issues and fatigue with cancer.
Make sure if you appreciated this video that you like it. We do appreciate that. That you
subscribe to us so you get our podcasts and share it on Facebook. That's helpful to us to get the
word out there so that we can help more people. Let me get a few to eat anything. Go to www.cuttersclatic.com.
Look at our clinic. We're gladly there to answer questions and we do have a nutrition store that
you can click on through there and get anything you need as well. So again, Dr. Cutters, thank you very much.